fear not they are not going to stop
because some images leaked this morning
I I honestly thought this was made up
it's so insane I really thought it was
made up but uh truth is far Stranger
Than Fiction these days uh this is from
the end wokeness Twitter account uh that
what you are seeing right there so of
course the original Seven Dwarfs 1937
can we zoom in on the original Seven
Dwarfs okay so that's the Seven Dwarfs
that we all know and love you got you're
sleepy your doc you're Dopey the rest of
them the usual set of characters they
are now remaking this into a live-action
movie and this is real ladies and
gentlemen look at this these are the new
Seven Dwarfs you may note that there's
only one dwarf there that's one thing
and then it's just a diverse or whatever
set of characters my favorite though is
rapey look at rapey over here look at
that one that is definitely raping uh
Andrew Andrew again you've been in the
business your whole life they are
wrecking they're wrecking the dreams of
the past what we all know and love and
then they put this and it's like they're
falling on their sword Disney knows this
is going to be mocked it is going to
lose money but the activists at the
company simply don't care and Iger still
I guess despite being better than the
previous chapic he still is doing it
Eiger made an amazing statement
yesterday where he said that they're
basically their TV and streaming arms
are not going to be core to their
company's profits yeah I thought you
guys yeah guess what well also on that
and then on the front page of the Wall
Street Journal uh last week is a story
saying that Disney parks are emptying
out and Iger is saying oh it's
absolutely absurd that we're trying to
sexualize our kid when Chris rupo has
released videotapes of their Skype sex
and assassins yeah Zoom sessions where
they're saying yeah we're going to
sexualize your kids uh yeah these guys
they do not know they're so surrounded
by people like themselves they do not
know we hate them and we do they do not
know that when we sit around and say you
know men can't become women you know you
listen live any way you please but men
can't become women they don't understand
that 99 of the country agrees with us
and the people who don't agree with us
are lying you know they agree with us
too and so they don't realize that until
I mean the big one is this Bud Light
thing with Dylan Mulvaney one can of
beer and they've fallen off the top the
number one beer in America has fallen
out of the top ten and still losing
money just because people are offended
by being forced to lie by having the FBI
take their tweets off by being hounded
for speaking the simple truth that we
all know this is this is gutted the the
Hollywood industry and Spencer is
absolutely right you know you walk into
the daily wire and people are creating
things they're saying things they're
they're not afraid we're constantly
being taken off YouTube we're speaking
simple truths I mean things that
everybody knows how long do they think
they can go so in this country this
diverse crazy free country how long do
they think they can go silencing the
truth before it just Rises up like a
gigantic dragon and bites them on the
ass and that is the moment that moment
is coming now and it's happening now and
only because conservatives don't really
understand the culture that well
Spencer I just had a great idea I don't
know if daily wire has the cash to get
the rights to Seven Dwarfs but I mean
Shapiro could easily play a dwarf come
on come on can they do what they did on
Lord of the Rings where they make us all
short because that would really that
would really rock